what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you have to decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future there's not a soul on
the face of the planet who understood
what the heck was going on in the Batman
comic in the 1960s anybody who tells you
otherwise is full of hoo-ha juice Batman
comics were so ridiculous in the 1960s
they make sense to anybody but here was
a deal okay so we've talked about Batman
being canceled and past right I mean
forward was almost canceled you know
this guy Fredric wertham wrote a book
said how many books were corrupting kids
the comics code Authority was formed and
they said well now we've got to tone
down Batman so he's not a vigilante
we can't glorify crime different things
like that and so the story just became
ridiculously outrageous and this is one
of those stories
welcome to the rundown guys this is a
story where I'm just like hey here is
something that I thought was kind of
cool and you guys should check it out
too
this one's a little bit different
instead of this being like yeah I
thought this story was amazing I'm like
oh this story is ridiculous
so this is the story of how Batman
became a baby now what we do is we just
pick up with that man and Robin going to
like this hideout like this guy named
nail spinning and this thing has a gang
and nail spinning hired a dude named
Garth now apparently Batman and Robin
his face off against nails at some point
along the line nail said he was going to
get his revenge any hired guards for the
purpose of exposing Batman to a
shrink-ray it would make him a little
kid so like Batman and Robin roll into
the hideout right there just like and
you guys are all going down so they
started beating the hell out of Oliver
ah to me it's just like BAM like he
punches one of them and they explode and
then suddenly Garth like blows out this
rain right looks like exposes Batman to
the shrink ray and then Batman like
shrinks down to the size of the kids the
nail stores like a smoke bomb and
suddenly everybody's immersed in smoke
and what is all-clear snails in his gang
are gone and then dick Grayson's like
damn
golly gee Batman like you're a little
kid holy pre-puberty that man you are a
little kid and so then Garth turns
around and like apparently took photos
of Batman as a kid because that's not
weird and then like nails them off to
the Gotham Gazette right and so the guy
the Gotham because that's like yeah man
Batman's like the most important person
in Gotham City right now because he's
like the only reason why we have people
who were afraid of crimes
I guess the smart thing for me to do is
to like show everybody to not be afraid
of Batman by publishing the photos of
him being a kid and so from here we
transition back to Garth and nails right
and Garth is like yeah man Batman
now like he's a little baby and nails
like yeah man we did it dude like you
know everybody tried to kill that man we
just made him a little kid meanwhile at
the Wayne mansion Bruce Wayne is sitting
on a pile of books because he's too
short to sit at the regular table
apparently they don't have a high chair
and you know he said things like man if
only there was a way to like undo this
by going back to the shrink ray so then
they start experimenting with him right
because I mean that makes sense a grow
man gets turned into a kid conduct
experiments and so they just start
having him like punch a bag and doing
gymnastics
apparently that baby has all the
strength of adult Batman and he still
got the mind of adult Batman and the
idea is to basically go back to the base
nail spinning and then just like beat em
all up and so they basically have Batman
that baby that's what you want to call
it Dick Grayson
they roll back over to nail spinning
right and like a big woman and just
don't like being the hell out of like
all these different criminals apparently
the news is getting wind of what's going
on and they're just like yeah man like
that babies are coming crooks eat just
because you're a kid doesn't mean you
can't be a hero even if you were an
adult and you were shrunk down to a
child despite the fact that defies all
laws of physics and is basically
impossible you can still be a superhero
now at this point we pick up with a girl
by the name of Kathy I think is Kathy
Cain she was that woman back in the
1960s but unlike Kate Cain as you're
reading right now and the amazing run of
Detective Comics Kathy Cain was crazy
she was like this obsessive chick right
she was just like one day I'm gonna make
like Batman Flash Bruce Wayne fall in
love with me and so she just like rolls
into his house why she's the Chang's
wife shows up in the middle of the night
you know like hey Batman let us get
together and les bump ugly so Batman's
like dude I do not want to have anything
to do with you
you are crazy chick I can see the crazy
in your eyes and so when she shows up at
the house right you know she's like hey
offer it is Batman here is Batman around
can I get with Batman you know and he's
like yeah he's just right over there in
that other room you can go ahead over
the library and you've away from there
well Sidda she turns a corner it looks
like Batman's making out with a chick
and she's like oh no my heart's broken
whatever that's Oh like she leaves well
they come to find out it was it it was
good great this is genius it was Dick
Grayson and bad baby they put up a
cardboard cutout of a dude kissing a
chick in order to trick Kathy came into
believing the Batman was making out with
some other chick so she leaves with her
heart broken and man is just kinda like
okay let's get back onto the wraps again
start fighting people lest we also
forget there is a moment where that baby
is on a swing I think we just need to
acknowledge that that happen this is all
in continuity guys this is all in
Batman's continuity this actually
happened about man this is not like an
else world story something alternate
reality this actually happened so what
Dick Grayson and Batman rolling back to
the lair of like Garth & Nail spending
all these different eyes they basically
go through and start beating them all up
here's the greatest thing about this
Dick Grayson is like hey I need to
create a distraction so Batman you can
get to the machine he does we never see
him use it instead suddenly now he's an
adult and so it's like okay well that
man's an adult now and then they beat up
all the criminals
you know they beat the hell out of them
probably killed him and then we have
Batman just basically take the back Navy
costume and make it a trophy for himself
that is the story of that baby isn't it
crazy as how Batman comics in the 1960s
were absolutely nuts and no one ever
really understands what in the heck is
going on with those okay so apparently
there is a story that explains why it is
that Batman and Robin are going after
nail spinning it is called the plants of
thunder Batman and Robin fight plants so
1960s Batman comics are like a treasure
trove of insanity nobodies does as
apparently like Batman and Robin show up
on the scene of a crime males pnina's
gang are like robbing this oriental
drooling Porter's place their dress and
asbestos suits you know I guess they're
like spraying people down with asbestos
I mean that's terrible asbestos causes
cancer like that's a terrible thing to
do but apparently I guess they were just
like running up on folks Batman and
Robin get inside the jewels store after
the criminals escape right and they run
upon the guy like hey man what happened
and he's like dude I don't know man
these dudes rolled up here like
abatement suits and they just part of
the plant and this plant grew almost
instantaneously and just started like
blowing heat towards the safe and safe
crack and then they made their escape
not only that well Batman's able to grab
a couple of seeds and go back to like
the Batcave and try to figure out how to
make them grow but can apparently this
gang nails Wendy's gang is like running
around and using plants for like a
multitude of purposes apparently these
are like swiss army plants like these
things can be used for like any number
of things sometimes they make stuff blow
up it's absolutely insane but we end up
having this guy that apparently has an
amnesia that shows up to Commissioner
Gordon is like hey man you know this guy
had these weird seeds in his pocket we
have no idea who this dude is well then
in the middle of all this whole
conversation Commissioner Gordon gets a
call from like
cop you know who's like yeah man these
guys were like hauling ass down the road
they ran us off the road and they
destroyed our car we need you guys to
respond and obviously what had they
destroy your car and it's like long
loading through seeds out the windows
and the things grew into these giant
trees and now they've destroyed the road
so Batman flies off in the Batmobile
right which is awesome because basically
Batman tricked out a 1960 Buick Deuce
and a quarter and turned it into the
Batmobile are you guys chasing down with
these guys and these guys start throwing
seeds out the window and like making
them grow they turn to try and plants
are like Batman and Robin are like
fighting plants trying to get to these
guys when they make their way
apparently these guys had more plants
they threw them onto the ground and then
like it froze the waterfall so I turn
into a walls they could climb up dude
this is this is absolutely insane well
from here somehow or another the guy in
the green suit is back with like nails
Vinny's gang I don't know how 1960s
Batman comics don't ask questions this
dude has no idea what's going on nail
spin he's like hey man you got to give
us more of that tonic that like makes
these things grow so we can like fight
off Batman and Robin because like Batman
and Robin are heading over there to the
location right so we're going to plan a
bunch of these cactuses and we are going
to have the kindnesses like shoot their
little barbs a Batman and Robin and it's
basically going to take them out well
because the fact of this dude doesn't
know how to give nail spinning or his
guys this stuff they need they just like
push him out of the way and he goes
flying into a wall come to find out when
this guy's head hit the wall he regained
his memory his amnesia went away this
dudes an alien all right this guy's an
alien from another group this is insane
this guy's an alien from another planet
who showed up here he had seeds nails
fini and his guys took the alien seeds
and started using them for their own
purposes and so like in the midst of all
this while Batman and Robin are like
fighting these cactuses they're biting
these plants the alien comes out and
like sprays the plants down shoots them
with some kind of an energy ray and like
the plants go back to the normal
position or whatever is and the aliens
like I'm never going to allow people to
use my plans for such devious purposes
so then like Batman and Robin basically
take out nail spinning in this gang
pretty easily and the alien is like hey
I really really appreciate it I'm glad
that you guys were able to take these
guys out I'm going to go ahead and grab
my plants and my seeds I'm going to go
home Batman's like cool man peace and
then they take nails finis and they
arrest them but somehow Nelson and his
gang got away but that is too dis is
absolutely insane dude 1960s Batman like
Batman comics in the sixties are like a
treasure trove of absolute insanity like
this is literally what happened I'm not
like
I'm not blowing things out of proportion
this is what happened in the comic this
is what took place here in this story
that I'm telling you about right now
this is why Batman in the 60s was insane
but yeah guys if you're new here two
comments explain you want to see more
insane Batman comics be sure to hit the
like button be sure to sub button become
part of the Rob core and leave a comment
down below let me know what you guys
think about crazy Batman comics because
there's a lot more where this came from
like there's stories where Batman's
killed guys that man has done some some
insane if there's the rainbow Batman
constant the one where he puts on like
all these different rainbow costumes
like it's absolutely insane that masks
how much back in the day but that being
said you all we're going to bring this
video to an end and I will catch you
guys on it
peace
[Music]
you